[Music]
foreign
is a misogynist at least that's what the
internet thinks I just known as The
Friendly sidemen member also known as
Bazinga now either has a podcast with
his Missus and a clip from it has gone
viral Kim says he won't propose to me
because I want to be Kelly Payne Faith
doesn't want to take my name just to be
clear her name is Faith Kelly I think so
she wants to do Faith Kelly pain being
his last name Faith doesn't want to take
my name and that irks me no yes I want
to take your name I just want to take
mine as well I'm not saying sounds like
she wants to have a kick and eat it not
like a woman I don't want to lose my
association with my family just to be
clear if you take someone else's name
you're still Associated to your family
who gave birth to your real estate and
did all that good stuff you don't lose
all that you still get to keep it I get
what she means I'm just I'm just messing
just like I'll get to the yeah stop
interrupting bro it's a personal thing
I've grown out with the name my whole
life I like it I'm Gonna Keep it no uh
that's a misogynist I bet he wants to
lock out of the kitchen sink and make
her do all the cooking and cleaning and
never let her out I just believe that
that's the that's how it should be done
no yes oh it's so sad to see a man go
down this road not even listening to her
does he even want to have a mind of our
own again this is your one example all
you do is repeat this name I don't care
you can tell this podcast isn't scripted
you gotta tell Big Dog yes we ain't
signing for this [__] you want all the
benefits we'll put my name on it then
we'll talk I just don't feel like it's a
big deal but that's the condition it
became a big deal because 10 million
plus views on multiple clips on Twitter
I prove this is a big deal to the rest
of the World by the sounds of it not
just about them it's what it makes
people feel about their own lives if you
want to be my wife then you'd be my wife
what the [__] well we have to explain
that this is marriage in the UK by the
way traditionally because marriage is
traditional we will put the man's name
on the end of the woman's first name you
know I will that's why it's in my name
but you're half being my wife you're
boring it bottle job yeah you had it in
the palm of your hands he bottled it now
let's go to the comments because you lot
have had a lot to say a block who will
shag and have a kid with someone without
getting married but draws the line at a
double barrel surname isn't traditional
they're just a misogynist I get the
point of tradition would be you get
married first then you have a child but
that doesn't take away from the
tradition of marriage within the UK
which is that the woman takes the man's
name which is the point he's making now
misogyny let's look that one up a person
who dislikes despises or strongly
prejudiced against women it's not really
misogynist does it to to right you want
this traditional wedding marriage let's
take the other bit of the tradition
which is you take the man's name I don't
think that means he hates all women
forgive me if I'm mistake in here but
what you've done is turned him into the
bad guy the misogynist which now means
that all women out there will look at
you as a right hero so you've done well
haven't you people just love
exaggerating things to suit what image
they're trying to portray it to their
own Twitter followers it's the classic
but luckily we've got this Knight and
shining armor just to protect us all
from bazinga's hit on women let her keep
the last name and let her go absolutely
this guy gets it you see because I know
you've had a kid with her and you know
you might love her and you've had a lot
of time together and you've really built
something up but you've disagreed on one
thing so get rid of her this guy's
Cutthroat he is cold people just need to
stop getting married it's an expensive
contract that benefits the women more
than the man I like the fact that he
says more than the man as if there's any
benefit to the man that is that is
that's optimistic you shouldn't need to
spend that kind of money to prove how
much you love someone I think there's a
little bit of Sensei actually because
this whole big expensive wedding where
you invite everyone who you've ever
known in your life to come and eat free
food and slap off the dress is a waste
of time oh we spent this much we love
each other more than all of you love
each other doesn't work like that so I
agree maybe just a little quiet wedding
somewhere is a better way to go than
going mental but people need to stop
getting married it's an expensive
contract that benefits women more than
men it only benefits women which is why
I can't understand why she doesn't want
it but we'll get into that soon Ethan is
going to be pronounced as misogynistic
and controlling unless he agrees with
his wife she's not his wife you can't
call her that yet but yeah pretty much
with it we're absolutely there but we've
really been lacking a bit of misogyny in
the sidemen so this just spices things
up a bit right although I thought it
would have been one of the other ones JJ
yeah we all were thinking it Ethan's
such a child mate if you're not going to
wife her because she wants to keep her
name as well as adding yours you've got
to question the entire relationship at
this point I'm sure he is well he's sat
holding his baby child go on your mother
doesn't have the same name as us what
will we do I get it's a key thing to
disagree on but still it doesn't bring
the entire relationship into disrepute
should I have a meeting with HR in the
morning this guy thinks he [__] owns
the place probably because he does he
could marry me tell you what pay all my
bills I'll take your last name anything
Pain's quite a good one it's quite
catchy it's just down to personal
preference at the end of the day
I love it when people play ball Tides
that's my job thank you uh she's clearly
not interested in being his wife she's
more interested in holding on to her
family name any woman who wants a double
barrel a man's surname is not ready to
commit solely to that man his purpose
and his life and ready to be his wife in
a traditional sense there may be a point
here we want everything our own way and
we're not willing to compromise on what
you have to give up to have titles such
as wife you want the wedding cake you
want the wedding dress you want the
Disney story but what about the man's
side of the Disney story what about what
we want in return for giving all of that
over now I don't know these two's
relationship but I'm gonna go out on a
hunch and suggest that Ethan makes a
[__] on more money than she does and
he allows her a very nice lifestyle I
personally if I was a woman and I was in
that scenario I'd be grateful to go to
you give me your name and I'll get all
of this [__] brilliant I'm your family
now you take me on board we're gonna
have a load of kids together fantastic I
get that that's old-fashioned but I
think that that's a pretty good
compromise in that scenario if you have
a traditional relationship but I could
be wrong let's look at some more
comments if you want both names
Incorporated I see no issue with that if
my daughter wanted to keep our family
name I'd be super proud well good for
you bro but have you ever considered
this what if she'd met a really really
rich man who was gonna make life very
comfortable and very easy and this was
super important to him would you tell
her [__] that guy [__] him [__] his
money tell him keep it and I'm not
saying money is everything before you
all get me on that one in the comments
you can't write it now even if he's just
a good guy and really this is really
important to him we're always taught as
men that we have to compromise for
women's needs and what women want and
yada yada but why is it so horrendous
for a man to care about you taking his
name when in the UK this is what we've
all grown up with and knowing and it's
because coming some sort of toxic thing
for a man to want that now if anything I
think that there's a a lot of love in
giving a woman your name and going we
are the same I I We Are Family you mean
so much to me that I want us to be on
the same team and yes some people can
look at that and go well why his name
why shouldn't be hurting him I'll tell
you why you know when the burglar breaks
in he's the first one down the stairs so
it's his [__] name sometimes
traditional it's based on thousands of
years of evolution where what a man was
supposed to be was the head of the
family and I know that because life has
changed now women are sort of revolting
against that but you can gain so much
from taking a man's name that some of
you are just overlooking quite frankly
women want to feel cared for provided
for protected men want to feel powerful
and respected and one of the ways women
can play into that is by taking our name
making us feel like that oh we shouldn't
need it oh yeah sometimes we just want
to feel special too and when a woman
thinks oh there's nothing I'd want more
than to take your name and to be your
girl and to do all the it makes men feel
[__] amazing it makes us feel loved
this is something women Overlook a
little bit in thinking that it's some
sort of horrific power struggle all
right there's a slight tint of you are
mine now but also we know that I am
yours we have the same name we are
building a family together and this
silly little fight over who gets to have
the last name because now women don't
want to give up any power at all because
the media have convinced you oh if a man
shows any dominance at all Revolt fight
back this is terrible meanwhile he is
providing everything in this scenario
cut him some slack [__] hell and when
you take a man's name it suggests to us
that you are completely and utterly
committed to being our woman and it's a
great feeling I just think that people
could be a little bit more open-minded
to just think that it's all about
oppressing women and keeping them in our
power and all of this rubbish because it
isn't that's not how men say it for the
most part for some men all right you
don't care fair enough each of the road
but for some men they really do want
that and fighting us about that all the
time you're fighting the wrong battle
really if a guy wants to give you his
last name it's because he adores you
think of it like that look I know some
women just don't want to feel like they
they need a man but like if you have a
kid with him you're joined to him for
the rest of your life anyway with or
without the last name and oh you get rid
of the man I don't need a man anymore
but you know when you're living in your
house a man built it you know when you
switch the lights on you put the
lectures on men men gave you that if you
anything goes wrong your toilet breaks
you need a [__] plumber to come it's
a man on the way someone breaks in the
house you need police to come you're
wanting a man to come this notion that
you don't need men it's just Pollocks
and fair enough like if you don't want
men you don't want to do the marriage
thing but that's each of their own but
like it feels like some people just want
all of the benefits of marriage and
without any of the give anymore to men
we're already getting [__] over in the
event of a divorce anyway the least
women can do is offer us a little fun
part and gift of like well I'll least
take your last name before I [__] you
over in the courts forget I said that
forget I said it let's all think
positively bro that's insane this is why
you should marry then have a baby he has
given that girl everything literally
everything and she can't be bothered I
don't think it's actually can't be
bothered a lot of women are so attached
and connected to their family they feel
like by relinquishing that last name
they're giving up that family they're
giving up the love uh that they have for
them they're not you're just creating a
new family now and one that you're gonna
have with this man and he is gonna help
you make them babies you know so how
many times are we gonna double barrel in
20 40 we're gonna have a kid with a
double barrel name having a a baby with
another [__] kid with a double barrel
name we're gonna have four [__] last
names all because people want to keep
their own an identity does that sound
ridiculous to anyone else no okay maybe
just me then brilliant so I think this
is actually a great topic that they've
actually put out there and even though
people are having a go and it probably
feels a bit crap for them right now I
respect them they've got balls to just
put this [__] out there like that I
think that this is a classic example of
why marriage is on the down and having
babies is on the down and women are
taking longer and longer and longer to
settle down because they don't
understand men and they don't understand
what's important to Men Women if you
want to wrap a man Around Your Finger
the easiest way to do it is to make him
feel like a king trust me on this and if
you want a man to love you then stop
fighting a man's nature which is to want
to have you as his and as much as that
can be oppressive if it's done in a
really toxic and nasty way if you have a
man who is a good man who loves you and
wants you to have his last name I don't
know what you guys are running from
because that is what life's all about
relationships being loved and being a
part of each other and I just think that
this is being overly Complicated by this
whole feminist thing where we can't even
approach the idea of belonging to each
other and having some sort of tradition
still a part of society where we want to
rewrite marriage and turn it into
something else well I've got news for
you that ain't marriage it's a version
that you've created to suit what your
needs are because you want everything
your own way and if you want the ability
to do everything that you want and have
it all your own way ask Sophie Turner
how that works out and some of you might
be triggered by some of the jokes I've
made but honestly I'm coming from a good
place here like I think that there's
some really good points to be approached
of how women can better understand men
through this sort of stuff and I know
that not all cultures do the whole
surname thing and that is quite a
British thing but for me as a man I
think it's a great thing and I think it
is important and I fully back Ethan
despite him not necessarily explaining
it in the best way on his podcast we
love it big love to them and don't
forget my podcast the true Geordie
podcast is coming back we've got the new
studio set up and ready the guests are
coming in thick and fast starting this
month big love to you all don't forget
to hit that like button stay subscribed
to the true Geordie YouTube channel
thanks for watching and peace